florian philippot votre tweet les
français ont bien plus à craindre de la
conque de poutine a fait énormément
parler y en a beaucoup qui ont dit que
c'était exagéré que c'était pas le
moment de faire ce genre de tweets
qu'est ce que vous avez à répondre à ce
tweet qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous
l'expliquer ouais mais déjà c'est bien
s'il a fait parler parce que le blanc
c'est concret au débat dans un pays
c'est intéressant ce que vous venez de
dire si vous aviez c'est pas le moment
c'est exactement ça c'est à dire qu'on
nous dit mettez vous au garde à vous
derrière macron puisque c'est l'union
sacrée bon d'abord la france n'est pas
un pays en guerre aujourd'hui ils ont
sacré c'est quand la france est attaquée
sur son sol oui mais oui mais on est
quand même on est solide ensemble parce
que pour ce qui se passe pour le service
ukrainien et on voit qu'il ya des morts
tous les jours forcément ça ça nous fait
pas plaisir mais si on doit se mettre au
garde-à-vous derrière deux présidents à
public en particulier en période
électorale quand il ya une guerre dans
le monde alors on sera au garde-à-vous
365 jours sur 365 puisqu'on a toujours
deuxièmement on nous dit bah il faut
vous mettre derrière macron parce que
macron basse et le savez que le garant
ici des libertés de la démocratie de la
restauration des trois non je suis
désolé moi je ne je ne signe pas ça ça
fait deux ans deux ans que ma kron a
créé un système en france d'apartheid
qui continue un plus personne n'en parle
mais il ya toujours un pas de la finale
cani deux côtés des millions de français
ça continue des gens qui sont considérés
par le même macro comme à emmerder et
des non citoyens je le rappelle donc des
leçons de ce bonhomme non deuxièmement
il ya toujours des dizaines de milliers
travers qui sont suspendus alors je vous
parle même pas de chômage des
infirmières des pompiers plus personne
n'en pas donc des leçons non j'ai vu
hier un maquereau intervenir à la télé
là 13h et dire je le cite ce conflit va
entraîner des conséquences durables et
profondes sur nos vies et donc je sais
pas très bien pourquoi à la fois qui
nous a annoncé les choses comme ça ça
s'est fini en confinement
puis en instauration d'un système de
passe etc restauration le vertige quand
même non non je pense qu'il pense aux
restrictions qui vont faire que le
pétrole la naissance de demander le gaz
le bolide le rhin alors alors qu'ils le
disent en mesure de pouvoir d'achat s'il
vous plaît donc le pouvoir d'achat des
français va être fortement impacté
puisque voilà il ya les licences il ya
le pain il ya le gaz on parle
l'électricité également donc forcément
on se dit au bout du bout à la fin du
mois ça va faire alors qu'ils
interviewaient les choses clairement et
qu'ils prennent les mesures pour que ça
n'arrive pas bon c'est pas tout à fait
ce qu'il a dit on sent bien on avait vu
ce qu'on a dit prendre les mesures même
s'ils baissent d'un centime l'essence à
la pompe safa 500 millions à l'état
chaque fois on vient si vous les voulez
on vient de dépenser 660 milliards
d'euros pour rien en deux ans de crise
qu vide qu'on a acheté par la fenêtre
pour indemniser les confinements extrait
qui l'ont servi strictement à rien donc
je pense qu'on n'est pas à 500 millions
on est plus à ces 500 millions près donc
si vous voulez moi je ne je n'accepte
pas ce garde à vous de me mettre
derrière un macron qui n'a jamais fait
la preuve est la démonstration qu'il
était un défenseur des libertés et de
l'état de droit etc je rappelle quand
même qu'on est depuis deux ans considéré
par the economist qui chaque année
établit le classement des démocraties
des dictatures dans le monde qui est
quand même reconnu ça fait deux ans et
ça n'était jamais arrivé que la france
est mise en démocratie défaillante c'est
sous macron un nom n'est plus on n'est
plus une démocratie d il ya eu des
événements qui ont fait que nos deux
pays et qui est classée aussi été
déclassées à cause de ce qui s'est passé
aussi avec la crise de covin non mais on
n'était pas obligé de gérer comme un fou
furieux la cuma du co lead s'appelle et
de créer de vous mettre en soute lui
tous les pays et beaucoup de gens
florian philippot 10 pour revenir à tu
vraiment une parenthèse rapide un disque
on s'en est mieux sorti que pas mal
d'autres pays je suis patient papillon
pas d'accord mais on va pas faire le
débat cofidis reconnaissez la position
on a maltraité les libertés comme
aujourd'hui il ya très peu de pays qui
ont encore des restrictions il reste
l'italie la france et est à peu près
tout alors que crm annonce la fin mars
ce sera terminé
ce sera suspendu oui ce sera levé non
elle croisait bien les mots qui sont
bien après on peut pas savoir ce qui va
se passer ducobu donc forcément on va
surprendre et puis si on a encore une
autre alerte on verra s'il ya une
nouvelle vague par exemple à la rentrée
et si malheureusement macro est réélu ce
que je ne souhaite pas on our dira
composent m c'est le masquer ma chambre
vous pensez il va être élu je crains
qu'ils utilisent énormément cette
affaire-là d'ailleurs il
n'utilisez pas candidat
je
pense madame depuis des mois y compris
sur le coville et ça va fonctionner
visiblement pour avoir des parrainages
et bien vous avez raison c'est beau mais
c'est vrai ce serait bien jugé région on
en est on est aujourd'hui dans un
système où quand on dit la vérité et ont
défoncé la misère des parrainages on
perd des parrainages de maires mais
j'assume parce qu'alors je pense qu'il
faut défendre la vérité juste florian
philippot les français ont bien plus à
craindre de macron que de poutine vous
êtes rendu compte de la portée de votre
tweet qu'on vous l'a été parce que
certains d'y faire le mans derrière
exprès ou des jeux alors je le pense à
100% je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de monde
qui le pensent et qui est d'accord avec
ça non et je vais vous dire une chose
pour le deuxième la deuxième lecture de
ce tweet c'est que par ailleurs moi je
cherche la paix la paix monsieur macron
poursuit une politique qui depuis 20 à
25 25 ans dans cette région ukraine
russie etc ne provoque pas à la paix ne
cherche pas à la paix j'aurais fait quoi
voilà alors moi je veux dire ce que je
ferais aujourd'hui je ferai une
conférence de paix je savais négocier un
traité de paix dans lequel on s'engage
on respecte notre promesse excusez moi
je respecte notre promesse de ne pas
élargir l'otan à l'ukraine
promesse je ne rappelle qu'elle serre
qui arrive à ces problèmes au début des
années 90 quand le pacte de varsovie qui
est elle au temps de l'urss disparaît ce
qui était logique en échange les
américains disent vous inquiétez pas on
ne va pas élargir l'otan à l'europe de
l'est ce qui a été fait entre temps ça a
été clair malgré tout pour expliquer aux
téléspectateurs aussi ce qui a déclenché
cette guerre c'est les essais que les
états unis veulent maintenant absolument
que l'ukraine rentrer dans l'otan la
russie y est fortement opposée et c'est
vrai je brise sms c'est vrai que la
promesse était que l'ukraine ne rentre
pas dans l'otan donc les etats-unis et
les pays européens ont changé d'avis
ensuite ce qui n'a pas plu également à
la russie à vladimir poutine sergueï
cécilia la bd là il ya un petit bémol
will que l'ukraine est un pays souverain
oui c'est ça et donc ce qu'il va pas
décider de l'ukraine ce qu'elle doit
faire ou pas bien sûr bien sûr au moins
lui demandait ce qui a déplu à poutine
et ont bien sûr explique les choses
pourquoi la réponse est tellement
disproportionné esquif actuellement cc
c'est déplorable comme tout comme tous
les pays disent mais ce qui lui a déplu
c'est qu'il n'est pas tenu leurs
promesses et l'attaquent de l'ukraine
c'est ça qui est grave je voulais la
question d'ailleurs à sérier elle y plus
destiné aux états unis
qu'à l'ukraine enfin bien je sais du des
fans des pauvres qui essayait cdc le
pays c'est l'ukraine qui en paye les
pots cassés et pots cassés vraiment
déplorable mais c'est surtout vers les
états unis donc c'est vrai que quand on
voit joe biden qui essaie de régler le
problème avec poutine on se dit il est
quand même responsable de ce truc à la
base il est un peu responsable oui c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs en fait avec florian
philippot jeu j'ai un peu avant problème
parce que il est souvent très fort pour
constater de les défaillances et sur les
défaillances je suis malheureusement à
80 % d'accord avec vous malheureusement
mais le problème c'est que qu'est ce que
vous proposez derrière vous proposez
s'allier avec un dictateur non vous
défendez par exemple un parti
nationaliste pour garder la souveraineté
française marine le pen est allé
chercher à être l'adoubé par poutine par
a brillé étrangers sont votre parti
votre ancien parti puisque vous l'avez
quittée a été financée par une
banqueroute et moi je alors qu'ils
financent assez intéressant oui d'abord
je n'y suis plus depuis plus de quatre
ans bon
2 les pattes fario il parlait du front
national oui parce que bon c'est
l'ancien partager un mouvement sur la
tête d'un box avec les patriots qui est
financé à 100% par les adhésions et les
dons passant par an plus tôt moi j'ai
pas de conflit d'intérêts je suis ni
financé par poutine ni financé par
l'ukraine est financé par un think tank
américain où atlantis parce qu'on a
beaucoup aussi ou de l'union européenne
ou l'otan je ne suis je suis en liberté
totale donc si je lui dise les soirs de
un jeu lego si je prendrais l'engagement
qu'on arrête de trahir la promesse sur
l'extension de l'otan parce que c'est
une agression s'est vécue par eux comme
une agression
bien sûr que ça va c'est des troupes
contient d'un petit que le pays se sent
menacée passionné ce qui se passait je
ne cautionne pas je suis pour la paix
oui notre monnaie sinon tu as écrit
rebuy donne est plus dangereux
éventuellement de footing ou deux crans
arrive à détruire a mené deux guerres au
nom de la paire je pense à il faut faire
il faut revenir au peuple il y a dans le
donbass des républiques autoproclamées
qui ont été effectivement reconnu en
violation du droit international par
poutine récemment et l'achat connu en
violation du droit international en 2008
les vrais sauvaud c'est vrai malheureux
corps mais sa vraie tout le monde disait
que c'était très bien on a faits ils ont
fait exactement la même chose on a fait
la même chose il faut faire des
référendums locaux sous supervision
internationale et on verra bien ce que
veut le faire le donetsk est lougansk
vous montrer à l'écran est ce qu ils
veulent être en ukraine indépendants ou
en roulant on va pas pleurer j'aurais
juste dire un mot si on continue dans la
même logique les sanctions et on
continue de l'union européenne l'otan
l'otan l'otan l'otan ma chance il faut
quitter l'otan d'urgence qui aurait dû
disparaître ya 30 ans et on continue
avec cet avocat bull air agressif vous
savez c'est hubert védrine l'ancien lit
des affaires étrangères français qui est
très sage et qui a dit hier la politique
occidentale gibert védrine oui
c'est pas aussi
sévère védrine sur le coût très bas
hubert védrine y avait de l'envié on
aurait dit des conneries écoutez là il
dit les choses devraient en tout cas
l'avis la politique occidentale et ils
violent par rapport à la russie depuis
25 ans et effectivement elle est noire
les inspecteurs des travaux finis auriez
vous préféré non mais vous préférez jean
yves le drian bah oui après ce qu'il
vient de dire cette nuit je rappelle que
l'otan est une alliance nucléaire c'est
pas dingue de dire des choses pareilles
non mais attendez je croyais sage et
kirkouk qui constate qu'on ferait mieux
de discuter de dialoguer et d'arrêter
d'agresser et c'est sans aucune naïveté
en pleine souveraineté moi je suis pour
la pleine souveraineté française plutôt
que l'agression klein philippe augé maps
que ce tweet si une agression les
français ont bien plus à craindre de
mâcon que de platine vous savez j'ai été
choqué oui absurde pascal ennemis vous
auriez dit byden est pire que poutine
j'aurais pas partagée du tout mais on
aurait pu comprendre un peu être la
promesse de l'otan mais la macro qu'est
ce qu'ils foutent là dedans pardon on a
pour les francs on est quasiment nulle
part dit-on les ukrainiens on en est
quasiment à 450 morts dans une guerre
qui dure que depuis qu'une journée on
est à la veille d'une troisième guerre
mondiale face à un dictateur
complètement fou et vous venez de parler
du pass vaccinale
mais ça n'a aucun sens
non pas du tout
mais qui va nous parler des cafés debout
plutôt qu'assis enfin je vous ai besoin
critique à ce métier votre uniforme est
allé défendre le dôme bas monsieur là me
tient tellement à calar à penser
vraiment alors vous pensez ce que vous
en pensez quoi un troisième guerre
mondiale
bah oui évidemment non mais attendez on
nous a volés ou qu'on nous appelle qu'on
stoppe sur l'irak en 91 troisième but
[Applaudissements]
on a parlé de la troisième guerre
mondiale reprenait les archives on nous
a fait le coup avec la guerre d'irak en
2003 à l'époque heureusement on avait
villepin et chirac qui ont dit non on
nous a fait le coup sûr la série on nous
a fait le coup sûr la serbie on nous a
fait le coup le même bhl qui dit là il
faut aller de combattre en russie bhl
qui dit ça il nous a dit il faut le
faire en ce sens libye souvenez-vous en
2011 - à l'époque déjà je disais ça va
être une grosse bêtise tout le monde
tombait dessus j'avais bien raison tout
le monde maintenant qu'il fallait pas le
faire donc la veille de la troisième
guerre mondiale si vous croyez vraiment
ces sottises la branche
celle des millions dépensés comme
strasbourg ce soir et vous ça vous
piquer sa florian philippot quand il dit
on n'est pas du tout à l'aube d'une
troisième guerre mondiale est-ce qu'on
peut il expliquer vos arguments on et
moi j'espère parce qu'on est pas la
langue du rabot n'est vraiment dalle
mais aller alors moi d'abord j'aimerais
lui dire j'aimerais lui dire une chose
monsieur filles pour vous avez des
grands discours policé ou non plutôt
police ont d'ailleurs dans certains cas
je trouve très simplement à leur parler
de financement
de financement avec des banques russes
vous vous êtes plutôt dans la
banqueroute que la banque russe
actuellement au nom savez bien que même
maintenant j'aimerais vous dire une
chose en partant là comment tout s'est
compliqué écoutez moi comment vous
expliquer aujourd'hui que vous seriez
plus à l'aise avec vladimir poutine par
si vous avez des espèces de connivence
fachos dictatorial que qu'avec emmanuel
macron moi aujourd'hui je suis sur la
liste de l'ani mire poutine et nemec
comme vous j'en ai pas vu beaucoup sur
le terrain ok c'est pas ce que ça va
[Applaudissements]
les buts rien dire
poutine je sais pas ce que ça mais je
vais d'abord à bien mais vous êtes un à
vérifier des couleurs grâce aux archives
est déjà une ligue 2 il a certainement
moi je considère que si vous n'avez pas
vu que macro et en une dans une dérive
autocratique c'est que des années des
années
qu'il est
[Musique]
c'est bien
ça doit vous connaissez pas
[Rires]
il n'est même plus possible de critiquer
le chef de l'état
avait dit le tweet crée problème
je suis un opposant politique et je dis
que pour les français macro est un vrai
problème pour nos libertés d'accord
il ya des gens maintenant ils sont
tabassés pour manifester aujourd'hui
dans l'est dans l'est alors ça c'est
vrai encore
ça n'existe plus les gilets jaunes qui
ont eu les yeux crevés ça n'existe plus
les ans et c'est un but à zéro ça
n'existe plus légendaires liberté il ya
huit jours qui ont été tabassés à qui on
a arraché le drapeau français qu'on a
acheté par terre comme aucun pays au
monde ne devrait le faire conclut
drapeau national voilà donc derrière
et je vote oui il s'est tourné très
certainement pas voiture non non je ne
regrette rien dur alors si je joue bien
et je suis sûr que macro on va tout
faire pour faire envenimer la situation
en ukraine pour deux ans
son intérêt c'est pas son intérêt si je
pensais pas sur l'intérêt
c'est parce que l'intérêt public la
kiffe 1 derrière moi en tout cas les
cinq six personnes derrière moi
c'est
très sympa chacun fait ce qu'il veut je
savais parfaitement le droit de défendre
les les milices
nazis d'ukraine si vous voulez alors
mais
le front national il n'y a pas des mines
est saisie bah moi je n'ai pas
demandé au front national dans ta c'est
quoi le but c'est quoi en france mais
vous
d'arguments vous partez sur des trucs
qui me concerne pas
les publics la première fois je suis
venu chez vous sur le cobp id quand je
disais on va avoir un pas salutaire pour
les restaurants j'avais le le comment il
s'appelle le reste soit disant manigold
pour les restaurateurs qui n'étaient
jamais il y aura deux pas salutaire pour
les restaurants et tout le public hue et
on vit en flandre il faut arrêter de
raconter n'importe quoi six mois plus
tard on avait le talent sanitaires dans
les restaurants voilà donc je veux dire
au bout d'un moment vous allez voir que
macro envenimera la situation il a quand
même déclaré cette nuit je cite la
guerre est là sur notre sol non je sais
pas que tout traité en france et
l'europe non europe
on à la présidence de laurent et la
france je sais pas ce que c'est que le
rac ans et auquel vous êtes allé
chercher aussi n'était pas la reine
n'est même pas dans l'union européenne
et moi je n'ai jamais été chercher un
sentiment ricine aux états unis ni
ailleurs
telepo non non ils s'étaient l'assemblée
c'est le front national époque
bien sûr et y était mais bon j'avoue ça
m'intéresse
si nos finances jamais allé en russie
monsieur philippe pons pardon vous
n'êtes jamais allé lui même jamais
enrichie ouais bah c'est bien ouais pas
très bien mais j'y serais allé sur gaza
et alors ici donc agi au piment la missa
énorme c'était bien pour qu'on se met
alors
à dix ans selon vous on n'a pas fait est
là même si la question si j'avais raison
michel en cours en russie seront avec
vous on n'a pas fait la même école pas
dire grand chose si j'étais à leur
succès
avait jugé pas dans l'annuaire des
anciens élèves comme vous l'avez dit
qu'on l'avait laissée sans reçoit
entendre que jésus vit toujours à
kamituga mythomane donc dans l'annuaire
de données large vous dit regardez moi
jamais non pas bien sûr que vous vous y
êtes moi je vous ai retrouvé moi j'y
suis donc pouvait pas de mise il était
barré par les
répètes classe d'ailleurs
c'est donc en amont merci mais était
alors s'il vous plaît
pour revenir aux élections il donnera sa
sergei le mytho et j'ai d'actions
sachant rien jaimito sur la wii comme là
bas n'est pas du tout
la
peau mais ça correspond à aucune à rien
moi c'était plus est les deux c'est
incroyable
florian philippot pas sur le fond du
sujet parce que excusez moi c'est quand
même un sujet grave et il ya des gens
et non
militaire quelle opération militaire le
temps à mener contre la russie pardon
quelle opération militaire sûr que nous
le ton a mené vous entendre il a alors
pourquoi parler de l'otan parce que
l'otan le temps était gris contre les
trois maladies dont et effet la ligne a
fait appeler la moitié de l'europe et
nourrit les dérives je me rendrai cet os
vient inaugurer les chars soviétiques
dans paris c'est sans merci ben oui
j'aurais fini